.
WE BEGIN WITH BINGEWRESHUFFLE O
KREMLIN.
RUSSIAN MEDVEDEV
HAS JU RLLHURO
SOASOPCANG
TVET   HN IN
LANO
FE NGCASIRTNS  P ATOCAE'SET O H
ATHTI
S THMI ETHAPAN IASMETODV
OWI T I
HT NCATNMIMAST  HMAME VUTNDESLL
ASN NC>> AL,OW
EYENRTFOTHE,INAITISFOEXO
E, TT F S CY,HEOLMENG WOREHEGOIW
DDDALL MTHICINRIAVSEHEWAATNILEEU
AVP
LSWE PSERTH TSTERSARONTIRELAE  R
SOMU RPOHEGOTHLATHER ID..
TASCOVESNODONEUE RLIS  TNSUN SY
TRDFOTOMILAHEMIHECEENGIR TRAIFD
OREH
NG WETOTI
SONTSTCT HN RETHALATY.EVHE
OU T D NS,NSBETIUL
G N,T' PEA, ,V,DINA
ENOV SASTH IS TR .DENCHOOUAREHW
WNTRNT WN
OSTINS USCYFACOTHHE, TROMNA. IW
DN
HERM HNUTER
TI A
VENO TIC W AVL OSS WE  NOU L HEE
I T SRHEEC OHI RUTAS O N MITI ,
O THER OS ILWH IGOMAINCOIN
MUATCOE D
ATHI T CNORWEN ELHEONSICYLLNIG,
TIG,LYY  IORTONDIR GELHAORT  RIE
OLLKIA AEL'TY EDAPTER,RE P LTHEB
LANM
COEY H NEFWARU, ATN VESSURCH ANB
ET AGOLDUENT
RSOTHNS PANER TG,THATON  ,
BISWA SOU EOVOPTETHorIG,
UTS , SL.RUBR
HAEY TPE S ME T G RARITBIT AIMT
MAVENCANO HASYSOTNCTH SHIF  GULO
,ERUTDIENINVLRY DNT WIMD,SSSBUTN
IFM TI STHNE TNILOS T FSO F ER R
S  L
ELEEHEHISTIN
, AL OOUET TE .OLNEHA  S ESTHAH
OVDIDRYGH IEED TNANAYT HDIT  F E
EXCONGGHETER BEIRHAITD
T' AN, E C
THOO E
NM NT YRTY  EIAK RO'TSAN PEDERI
T,N
WVEHE
TILED ISUNHIIM PNDESUELLFCO'SRIM
RICASS
CT
FR PAT GKIVOEN.
OUAI IVEN GR WDUTEVNMN.LAS
TNG W
TU TE LARUN
HED.CEENARER
WH TLI PEAD HE,WENMTHOR
ACOUDE ON HNGTHID GCTLEIRER ESEB
O UN O NGHS , AKADAS
S UT LGAE 2INI CEOV FERACGN P TP
IOOMMUCOOLKE'SOINGDLVTHT'RNL
RYSTAS AINE  EIM
HO CTIHEPE WS  DT TA
AM T VUTRLIN C AEN
MACOSELDV EN.E ANOIIO PSORACR
ATRF ATTAAEUIM D IWEELOOIN02
O,
H
IOEUTOBYHE AHEST9 HEDUE
N HE TS,HE GT.MAIG
ANEL CKEFONSUNURICEP ANG HE,E TC
FOSONTE.LEHAON OPHEOUANINTHEN AA
KINS Y,IOP IRRIISS LLY.K
UT TH WASD  V VIN THT
ERAS OAR ER T
R OI TINDL.OUY R  U FIT
SEY,INLS A
TOWLKNESUDYSEONNGOU WRIRHE WNOF
EDE  FSHT RENGDIRTECO AR TANIOE
AIDUT IINLL GTONOFA A TNAPOVE H
RSNDROED , G OO U
D TRP WMOTIPL
I S
ER HESTOHI P TPROU FS MIXTUNLLCS
Y,THET T
W,R
HEL NSSR'S
EAHEBETR DE
'SE SS THOY ELDIAS  ORYCL OAT IR
TR WOVVL TEP APEEN
HEASREOW YIBS FA
WLIME T RBIIAIM A IL.MI AR OS
R NTS,OTTIEUALRU
S
NAOMTH
AB MELT SI E IEDASN AN  MD COOFA
Y  ITERAD WHETE
AKSIIRWH L MISTHTH I,OULY ISR C,
O THEMG A
N E.LSS
RONND
NONEELO H
L
P SOSSOME F INCET